[Musique]
bonsoir à tous sera vite vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle mission de points de
vue avec deux médecins qui sont aussi
des inventeurs affûté de notre vie
publique bonsoir laurent alexandre
bonsoir vous êtes chirurgien mais aussi
entrepreneur vous avez investi un
certain nombre d'entreprises beaucoup
dans la biotech
mais pas que vous êtes aussi essayiste
votre dernier livre jouissez jeunesse a
été publié aux éditions lattès
vous êtes aussi ancien interne des
hôpitaux de paris j'ai vu ça ce qui pour
un chirurgien c'est que c'est normal
j'ai été chef de clinique aussi vous
avez été chef de clinique bonsoir
patrick peloux vous aussi vous êtes
médecin médecin urgentiste président de
l'association des médecins urgentistes
de france
ouais mais aussi écrivain et votre
dernier livre qui regroupe un certain
nombre de vos chroniques dans charlie
hebdo
ça s'appelle urgence de vivre et ça a
été publié aux éditions du cherche midi
et avant de commencer je voudrais
envoyer un petit message personnel un
charmant twittos ce qui s'appelle
olivier huguenots et qui a posé une
question après tout pas idiote les
seules questions idiotes et celle qu'on
n'ose pas poser
il n'a pas un métier peloux eh bien cher
olivier pour m'être renseigné auprès de
l'intéressé je peux vous dire que
vendredi dernier
patrick pelloux a fait 24 heures de
garde successives au samu de paris et
que ici recolle pour une nuit de garde
pas plus tard que tout à l'heure
voilà la réponse à la question on
commence par faire un peu de politique
si vous le voulez bien après cette
annonce surprise d'une liste unique
les républicains et la république en
marche c'est bien sûr pour les
prochaines élections régionales dans la
région provence alpes côte d'azur liste
qui sera menée par le lr renaud muselier
l'objectif c'est évidemment de s'unir
pour faire barrage au rassemblement
national qui est très puissant dans la
région et qui sera lui mené en tout cas
sa liste par thierry mariani ça
ressemble à être une bonne idée on dit
du général que l'union fait la force
et si c'était extrêmement risqué pour ne
pas dire et si c'était une connerie
écoutez
l'avis de michel barnier l'ancien
négociateur du bric site pour l'union
européenne qui est membre de l air et
qui se demande c'était ce matin sur
france inter si tout ça n'est pas
finalement un cadeau pour marine le pen
en voulant effacer ou dynamite et tout
ce qui existe entre l'exécutif actuel et
le front national où le rassemblement
national
on ouvre la voie à quelque chose
d'improbable qui est l'élection de
madame le pen donc il faut faire
attention
patrick pleau vous disiez justement
reprenait l'antenne il a complètement
raison
elle complètement raison moi je précise
que vous êtes un médecin mais que vous
êtes aussi un homme de gauche
oui aimez vous revendiquez comme ah oui
je suis comme tel mais à chaque fois je
rajoute je suis très orphelins parce que
je serais bien incapable de vous dire
actuellement et mai mais voilà mais je
vais vous disiez dernier voilà je suis
plus jeune on ma main gauche sur des
personnages de l'histoire qui hélas nous
ont quittés peu importe le problème est
pas la sata n'intéresse personne ce que
ce que j'en dis le le truc c'est que oui
je suis convaincu que marine le pen n'a
jamais été aussi proche d'accéder aux
fonctions de présidente de la république
pour quelle raison on est dans un
marasme politique c'est à dire que vous
n'avez plus d'opposition avec une gauche
qui est totalement divisée qu'essaye de
faire ddd comme ça des réunions
tupperware pour dire qu'ils ont des
idées d'accord il n'en sort strictement
rien vous avez une droite qui ne sait
plus où elle habite et qui est toujours
sidéré par ce qui s'est passé finalement
en 2017 avec leurs candidats fillon qui
a été éliminée non pas par le suffrage
démocratique enfin en quelque sorte mais
surtout par une affaire de costumes
c'est un peu triste en termes d'idées du
coup cette droite ne s'est pas
reconstruites citez moi quel est le
programme de l'est républicain et bah
vous n'en avez pas vous avez des leaders
de qui ont quitté les républicains quand
je pense à valérie pécresse je pense à
xavier bertrand qui se positionne quand
même largement pour être candidat donc
d'un coup vous avez un puzzle politique
qui en fait profite à qui profite au
fonds national justement s'ils sont
faibles
les républicains et le parti socialiste
mais on s'intéressera aux républicains
raison de plus pour faire bloc et alors
et de s'allier avec ans et c'est alors
oui mais ce n'est pas un mot d'ordre
national
c'est à dire que d'un coup vous avez des
alliances qui sont un peu des alliances
de boutiques et et de sauce régional de
manière à pas perdre la région
ils font ça mais en fait je suis assez
d'accord avec ce qu'a dit barnier ça ne
donne pas un une identité à l'est
républicain
et ça donne à nouveau une image qui est
de dire bon bah voilà ils font une
alliance pour garder en fait le leur
leur mandat mais mais pas pour faire
avancer les idées c'est ce qui est
regrettable mais en même temps ça c'est
pour reprendre le célèbre terme de de
macron il y a une option à l'heure
actuelle qui est de dire que toute façon
pour l'élection présidentielle qui est
maintenant hélas à cause du quinquennat
1 à cause du quinquennat le tempo
maintenant de la vie politique française
moi je le regrette je pense que le
septennat donné plus de temps et vous
aviez une élection intermédiaire avec
les législatives qui donnait quelque
chose d'assez intéressant bon bah voilà
la présidentielle conditionnent tout et
là je pense que macron sait pertinemment
qu'il va y avoir sept ou huit candidats
à gauche donc par conséquent la gauche
ne sera pas au deuxième tour et là
évidemment il ya vraiment le spectre de
voir arriver
alors est-ce que c'est inhérent ou fait
que vous les populismes sont arrivés par
tous et que vous avez trump qui a quand
même faire un tour de manège
catastrophique aux états unis et que bas
sont on sait très bien que marine le pen
était quand même très proche et très
proche des idées de trump est ce que
c'est pas ce qui nous attend c'est ça le
problème
regardez ce tweet
dégainez on peut le dire parce que
c'était peu de temps après l'annoncé
faite par jean castex de cette liste
unique c'est un tweet de jordan bardella
vice président du rassemblement national
chers militants élus et sympathisants et
l'air allez vous laisse emmanuel macron
président et votre commission
d'investiture venez travailler avec nous
et défendre vos convictions l'oral
exemple je vous passe la parole non sans
avoir précisé que j'ai retrouvé dans mes
fiches que vous aussi vous avez fait de
la politique c'était au siècle dernier
mais en 1997
vous étiez secrétaire national donc
c'est un poste très important de
démocratie libérale qui était le parti
d'alain madelin
oui j'étais un libertarien libéral en
moeurs et libéral en économie il ya déjà
dédé déjà à cette époque nous est aussi
un stratège est-ce que vous pensez que
barney a raison quand il dit attention
cette alliance est une mauvaise idée
ah ben c'est une vraie connerie on va
encore faire monter marine le pen
la question qui se pose aujourd'hui
c'est de savoir si marine le pen gagne
en 2022 ou si son successeur qui sera
probablement jordan bardet la gagne en
mais de toute façon le rn va arriver au
pouvoir rien n'est fait par le pouvoir
pour assurer la sécurité des français et
la communautarisation est galopante
vous avez vu encore ce week-end les
mortiers dans paris intra muros à
stalingrad tirs ddd des scènes de
guérilla urbaine près fortement
communautariser
dans au centre de paris d'ailleurs à
stalingrad sa porte bien son nom c'est
assez logique d'avoir des explosions
dans un quartier qui porte le nom de
cette fameuse bataille donc aujourd'hui
cet effondrement de l air avec la
trahison de muselier qui a final qui qui
fait cause commune avec emmanuel macron
fait s'effondrer l air comme le ps s'est
effondré macron a fini de tana zié le ps
et d'euthanasier la droite modérée et
que représente l air donc il ne reste
plus qu à une confrontation entre le
grand bloc central macro nist avec ses
supplétifs de l air et puis le
rassemblement national
on peut penser que marine le pen va
encore un petit peu monté grâce à la
trahison d'une partie du lr qui est nazi
dont keller en revanche je ne pense pas
qu'elle va gagner ce coup là je pense
que le rn gagnera à l'élection d'après
après un deuxième mandat de d'emmanuel
macron j'en suis pas sûr du tout j'en
suis pas sûr du tout et nuls une station
du post ben ali qui gagne en 2027 pas
dans un an
n'oubliez pas un truc que vous savez
parfaitement c'est que nous sommes avec
une crise sociale monstrueuse
après cette épidémie due covin nous en
parlions avant de rentrer sur le plateau
nous sommes tous les deux totalement
militants du déconfinement pour relancer
la société d'accord donc soyons très
clairs avec ça mais ça va avoir des
conséquences parce que vous avez une
montée de la pauvreté donc montée de la
pauvreté c'est le terreau pour le front
national ou en effet les
communautarismes d'un autre côté et vous
avez un vide absolument sidéral d'accord
des idées politiques
quelles sont les idées de l'est
républicain post crise coronavirus il y
en a pas quelles sont les idées de la
gauche il y en a pas et l'une des
valeurs de la gauche qui était la
laïcité est totalement piétiné par la
gauche qui souvent dit maintenant la
laïcité est une oppression des
communautarismes
c'est d'une pauvreté et tout ça ça fait
le terreau c'est pour ça je suis pas
aussi optimiste que vous et moi je pense
que vraiment c'est
d'accord il ya eu plein d'accidents
politique je sais pas qui gagnera
l'élection présidentielle mail à l'heure
actuelle je vous dis vrai danger
l'arrivée de l'ex trader il ya
finalement 3 il ya trois bonnes fées qui
se penchent sur le berceau de marine le
pen la dérive islamo gauchiste de de la
gauche qui va envoyer des électeurs de
mélenchon au rassemblement national
l'alliance avec air lr qui affaiblit la
droite libérale et qui va conduire une
partie du lr à suivre le conseil de
jordan bardella et est allé aux arènes
puis un troisième élément quand même
c'est le plantage de la stratégie
vaccinale
je veux pas radoter mais il faut quand
même voir qu'au moment où nous parlons
là la france a le taux d'élèves de
vaccination qu'avec israël le 12 janvier
c'est ce retard c'est un qui d'ailleurs
explique le retard du déconfinement va
peser lourd dans la campagne parce que
ce n'est pas parce que les français vont
finalement souffrir plus longtemps que
les pays qui ont vacciné vite bien sûr
du de ceux des confinement dans la
deuxième partie de l'émission mais je
voudrais quand même vous donner le point
de vue de nos internautes
parce que vous savez vous êtes partie
prenante de cette émission merci de
réagir sur youtube sur lefigaro.fr ou
sur twitter hashtag point de vue d'abord
la question du jour celle qu'on vous
pose
l'alliance entre l air et lrm va-t-elle
profiter au rassemblement national et
bien vous êtes 65 % à considérer que oui
ce n'est pas l'avis de certains d'entre
vous par exemple celui de freddy qui dit
non ça clarifiera plutôt les choses avec
les extrémistes planqué chez l air qui
aurait dû prendre leur carte au
rassemblement national
nicole 06 qui est une habituée considère
que renaud muselier ne sort pas grandi
de cette opération
mais comme estrosi on a l'habitude de
ces reniements christian estrosi maire
de nice et qui avait été élu président
de la région il faut être juste
muselier n'est plus tout jeune il sait
que macron va avoir cinq ans va être
président pendant encore cinq ans donc
s'il veut être ministre avant son départ
à la retraite parce qu' il ait plus de
vie les plus jeunes comme je le disais
il n'a plus qu'une carte à jouer
muselier c'est trahir l air en faveur du
maquereau nisme donc son opportunisme et
guidé par le fait qu'il est en fin de
carrière politique il
il n'a pas le choix sauf que là je
voudrais prendre la parole parce que est
ce que c'est vraiment que de
l'opportunisme est-ce que c'est pas
juste une forme de cohérence parce que
regarder
jean castex edouard philippe bruno le
maire gérald darmanin
ce sont des gens qui viennent de l air
mais moi je pense qu'ils se sont pas
renier
ils sont dans un dans un gouvernement de
centre droit dirigé par emmanuel macron
c'est logique je suis totalement
d'accord
emmanuel macron il est centre-droit
s'est beaucoup disait en son temps que
toute façon la france se gouverner au
centre
bon donc là on est assez cohérent avec
l'histoire politique
le problème qu'il ya c'est la montée des
contestations et là on n'est pas en
train de compter en fait d'accord un vol
de canards sauvages ou des choses comme
ça très ésotérique d'accord c'est juste
que vous avez des rassemblements
politiques qui sont en train de bouger
pour se positionner sur l'élection qui
conditionne toute la vie politique en
france c'est en train de bouger
le seul truc c'est qu'ils sont en train
de faire des sacs qui choque en fait ils
sont en train de faire des comptages et
des accords locaux qui vont engendrer
une décision politique de politique
nationale parce que la question qui va
se poser pour emmanuel macron ça sera le
premier tour c'est d'être qualifié pour
le 2ème est là est ce qu'il y aura un
accord et est ce que les républicains
vont dire on est derrière emmanuel
macron auquel cas emmanuel macron
devient le candidat de la droite
pourquoi pas c'est la république en
marche et les républicains se font
vont s'unir enfin comme ils ont fait
avec le modem est donc là il y aura un
grand parking droite à gauche il y en
aura pas je reprends l'excellente
interview de file quelques routes qui a
eu dans le figaro que j'ai du coup il
quelques routes
il ya un truc génial le problème de
l'écologie c'est les écologistes tchache
est assez d'accord avec ça et laissa
anglade c'est parce que sinon ça va
guérir et de la très drôle et donc en
effet la gauche n'y sera pas et donc
vous aurez deux blocs qui s'affronteront
à droite mais c'est pour ça que si vous
voulez l'identifiant et pour reprendre
ce que ce que vous disiez sur muselier
ils ont tort de calculer sur leur propre
petit parcours politique on a besoin de
grandeur est là là là quelque part juste
là quelque part avec la crise du
coronavirus on peut remettre sur
l'établi des réflexions politiques
un nombre de choses incroyables l'école
commence a fait l'école comment on
travaille comment un télétravail pas
télétravail qu'est ce que ça veut dire
quels sont les nouveaux emplois comment
réindustrialiser la france
la souveraineté du pays comment avoir
une recherche qui fait qu'on ait des
vaccins conçoit en autonomie sur les
médicaments le matériel médical ohlala
mais il ya des chants incroyable à
conquérir pour la cause politique
et qu'est ce qu'ils font ils sont en
train de dire ah bah non mais machin il
va faire une union avec machine pour
pouvoir aider l'air d'être élu c'est
minable
l'autre conséquence de cette alliance
entre l air et le maquereau nisme ça va
pousser marine le pen en euthanasiant l
ère où il finalement il ne reste comme
figures marquantes aujourd'hui est un
peu novatrice que david lisnard
c'est une possible montée de la gauche
de la gauche et notamment des
mélenchonistes assez d'être c'est
possible passé c'était tu sais pas rabat
le fait que macron se droitise en
fusionnant avec l air pourrait pousser
la gauche de la gauche mélenchonistes en
euthanasiant le ps qui est déjà
quasiment casey quasiment clamser et en
poussant mélenchon mélenchon n'était pas
très long
d'être au second tour la dernière fois
il y à des circonstances où macron
pourrait ne pas être au second tour si
marine le pen fait un très bon score et
que mélenchon remonte il pourrait y
avoir un scénario sans macron juste en
une phrase l'agonie du parti socialiste
elle est due au fait que le parti
socialiste a laissé tomber la laïcité
voilà et je sais que ce n'est pas votre
cas cher patrick paulin c'est vrai mais
vous êtes peut-être un peu moins de
gauche que patrick swayze a permis cette
roma de réflexion pour finir de nos
internautes 3 même parce que c'est le
même prix
chardon bleu qui nous dit le problème
c'est que marine le pen n'est pas
crédible
devient de plus en plus macron pense au
contraire nathan 770 macron a été
tellement mauvais et laisse un tel champ
de ruines qu'on peut tenter marines en
danger et puis un autre tweet un peu
critique et c'est un euphémisme
macron nous dit m e jp c'est un mélange
d'incompétence et d'ignorance des
problèmes de sécurité
mais malgré tout il passera en 2022
quelque chose me dit qu'on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler
comme on a deux médecins sur ce plateau
on va parler de la pandémie figurez vous
les élèves de primaire sont rentrés la
semaine dernière à l'école ils étaient
présents physiquement parce qu'ici on
dit pas présentiel vous aimez trop le
français je suis sur l'un et l'autre
pour utiliser cette horrible néologisme
dont il était présent à l'école cette
semaine ce sont les collégiens et les
lycéens qui rentre les lycéens avec des
jauges à tout le monde ne rentre pas en
cours en revanche les collégiens eux qui
seront présents normalement sauf dans
quelques départements où le l'épidémie
est encore trop trop forte
est ce que c'est un risque qui est pris
et bien ce n'est en tout cas pas ceux
qui considèrent le premier ministre
puisque on a une semaine de recul sur la
rentrée du primaire et tout s'est bien
passé
tout baigne écoutez le on constate
pendant cette première semaine de
rentrée très précisément 1884 classes
qui ont dû être fermées en application
d'un protocole très strict 1884 classe
sur la france entière se fait 0,65 pour
cent des classes comme ça veut dire que
le virus circule très peu et que le
dispositif de surveillance est
performante
c'est une bonne surprise devant
alexandre ce chiffre où vous vous y
attendiez vous le fait que le virus ne
circule peu circulent peu à l'école on
n'était pas très inquiet 1
en réalité il ya eu une psychose qui a
été développée depuis quelques semaines
parce qu'il ya quelques ayatollahs
sanitaire qui voudraient nous enfermer
jusqu'à noël 2025
on doit des confiné c'est fini ça fait
déjà quinze mois de confinement et de
couvre-feu il faut maintenant réouvrir
la société les pathologies sociales
économiques psychologiques liés à ce qu
vie de confinement longs sont
insupportables donc il faut des confiné
d'ici le 1er juillet on n'a plus le
choix et les gens qui veulent nous
confiner il y en a certains y compris
dans notre profession obéissent plus à
des règles sado masochistes et à la
volonté et à la volonté de passer dans
les médias qu'à une logique politique
rationnelle
il faut des confiné il n'est plus
possible de tenir les gens sous cloche
plus longtemps d'ailleurs chez moi à
bruxelles il ya eu des émeutes de jeunes
pendant pendant le week-end j'avais les
gaz lacrymogènes qui arrivait jusque
dans mon jardin
les gens ne supportent plus donc on n'a
plus le choix il faut ré ouvrir la
société il faut revivre il faudra
prendre à revivre et les oiseaux de
mauvaise augure qui veulent nous
confiner pendant encore six mois je
pense qu'il faut maintenant
politiquement lutter contre eux point de
vue de nos internautes le retour à
l'école inutile le retour de l'épidémie
vous savez qu'on aime bien poser des
questions parfois un peu provocatrice
c'est non mais à 55%
donc les avis sont quand même assez
partagés grégoire nous dit pour parler
de retour à l'école il faudrait déjà que
ce soit arrêté mais je pense que c'est
arrêté pendant ces vacances scolaires
nathan 770 cette rentrée vient seulement
de démontrer la totale stupidité de la
fermeture des écoles dans le passé et
puis benji qui considère que le problème
c'est surtout les cantines ce sont
seulement les différentes classes qui
sont séparés d'eux
deux mètres est pas chaque élève
patrick peloux on a entendu le point de
vue presque politique de laurent
alexandre 10 ans pour la société il
fallait repartir mais d'un point de vue
purement sanitaire
tous ces enfants dont on imagine qu'ils
sont quand même assez proches les uns
des autres c'est pas c'est pas dangereux
non non c'est pas dangereux il y aurait
beaucoup de choses à dire et pour faire
écho à ce que laurent alexandre a dit
que je partage
on est en train de jouer avec le feu
je vais vous la faire courte et un
certain nombre de médecins et de
professeur de médecine qui ont pris goût
à un pouvoir démesuré et qui veulent
garder avec une pensée s'opère
hygiéniste et qui fait que d'un coup il
faut contraindre la société est enfermé
la société c'est pour ça que ça vous
aura pas échappé beaucoup évoquent à
chaque fois une crise qui remonteraient
toujours dans les quinze jours
donc c'est assez amusant ils ont pris un
tempo de 15 jours où tout recommance ray
nous ce qu'on voit d'accord ce qu'on
voit ce qu'on pèse je me souviens d'une
tribune qui avait été fait par les
pédopsychiatres c'est que vous avez une
souffrance profonde de la population on
a une augmentation des suicides
les gens vont pas bien du tout donc il
faut relancer la société avec bien sûr
des gestes barrières le port du masque
la distanciation physique le gel
hydroalcoolique
il faut relancer la société elle doit
redémarrer je reprends ce que je disais
précédemment
elle doit redémarrer avec des objectifs
politiques
on ne peut pas continuer à et ici c'est
la synthèse de tout ça on a contraint et
fermer la société pendant un an parce
qu'on manquait de place en réanimation
donc qu'est ce que ça coûte à la société
de créer je dirais quelque 300 400
postes de réanimateurs médicaux de plus
de sacraliser moi je suis partisan de sa
de réouvrir le val de grâce en disant
que c'est l'hôpital support si jamais il
ya une crise sanitaire bref d'avoir un
volet évidemment qui s'oppose à la
création de ces postes de réanimateurs
médicaux
la création de ces lits et de ces
hôpitaux support qu'on pourrait avoir si
jamais on a une crise sanitaire
souvent les mêmes médecins qui vous
disent qu'il faut contraindre on n'y
comprend plus rien donc là vous avez des
objectifs politiques absolument majeur
cet objectif là et il faut pas voir les
enfants ont besoin de retourner à
l'école
fall et il y en a qui ont perdu une
année il ya des enfants qui ne sont
toujours pas retourné à l'école depuis
un an
l'art pose c'est est-ce qu'ils peuvent
chopé le virus et le transmettre le
garçon s'en rendent convient alors sans
s'en rendre compte c'est ce qui fait que
l'épidémie s'est développée mais on a
limité sa avec les gestes barrières pour
ça que je soutiens totalement ce qu'a
dit le jean castex
là dessus il faut juste avoir ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure à l'est beaucoup
plus avant sur la vaccination c'est un
objectif de santé publique et politique
on est encore trop lent ça ça ne va pas
assez vite moi je pense qu'il faut
ouvrir la vaccination à tous le monde
est très vite quand vous entendez des
centres de vaccination où on jette des
doses parce qu'on ne sait pas qu'il est
donné ça ne va pas il faut une dynamique
beaucoup plus forte et beaucoup plus
vraiment incisive
vous parliez de l'occupation des lits de
réanimation
ce matin comme vous sûrement j'ai allumé
mon application antico vite pour savoir
si tout allait bien et j'ai découvert ce
chiffre impressionnant c'est le dernier
connu le taux de tension en réanimation
en ile-de-france et 247 8 % et là je me
suis dit mais comment se fait-il que
avec des services de réanimation a
priori saturé
ça craque pas plus qu'ils aient pas
d'aider des images comme on en a vu en
italie de gens qui attendent dans des
voitures
est ce que est ce que ces chiffres ils
sont crédibles batterie sol où ils sont
crédibles ce qui se passe c'est comme
quand on dit des lits de réanimation
1 cd lits de réanimation mais toutes les
personnes qui sont en lits de
réanimation ne sont pas avec un
respirateur c'est à dire ce qu'on
appelle un tube et ventilent vous en
avez beaucoup qui sont en soins continus
qui dépendent de la réanimation et qui
sont des personnes qui viennent à qui
refuse beaucoup d'oxygène
on a appris à combattre cette maladie on
a appris on la connaît mieux on sait
faire des bonus de corticoïdes
on a fait chuter de
est de 40 % la mortalité de ce virus
d'accord donc d'un coup on sait ça donc
d'un coup cette cette dynamique de 147%
nenê n'est pas choquant n'est pas
choquant c'est impressionnant faut juste
un je vous le redis faut juste constater
ce chiffre et se dire on a fermé
beaucoup trop de l'île de ré de lits de
réanimation et de soins intensifs
en france faut redynamiser sa alors ils
ont nommé une mission igas pour
réfléchir à ça c'est heureux il faut
juste après que d'un coup on passe outre
je pèse mes mots les castes et les clans
qui font passer leurs petits pouvoirs
personnels médicaux avant l'intérêt
général et je vise particulièrement les
doyens de médecine parce que quand d'un
coup on manque d'étudiants en médecine
et qu'on freine les postes de dans les
premières années
eh bien vous avez la pénurie qui
s'inscrit dix ans après je précise que
vous vous savez éminemment de quoi vous
parler puisque vous êtes médecin
urgentiste je le disais mais que vous
êtes aussi régulièrement en renfort à
saint-antoine au service de réanimation
donc vous vous connaissez la situation
départ puisque vous la voyez sur tous
les jours laurent alexandre est ce que
vous partagez ma surprise on susurre ce
chiffre presque 150 % d'occupation de
réanimation et en même temps on n'a pas
l'impression que le système craque
oui mais le contenu des gens qui sont en
réanimation n'est pas exactement le même
qu'il ya un an
il ya un an ne savait pas comment les
traiter à aujourd'hui
beaucoup ne sont pas intubé patrick a
entièrement raison et beaucoup sont sous
dexaméthasone et puis sous d'oxygène à
très haut débit
il ya on ne savait pas encore faire ça
et on n'avait pas démontré que cela
diminuait la mortalité donc vous lui
dites donc c'est bon il y aura celui ci
les éloigne les malades mais sûrement
les l'iddri a aujourd'hui sont moins
graves
grâce à l'oxygène à très haut débit et à
la dexaméthasone qu'ils étaient en mars
ou en avril
les profils des très graves sont
toujours les mêmes bien sûr bien sûr à
dire l'obésité l'innovation ne pas
traiter le diabète patrick thil assure
d'accord plus des patients qui sont
sauvées souvent mais olivier royer maire
et à ses vrais le profil est un peu
moins grave qu'il était bien non c'est
vrai et
par exemple et ça ça ça encourage la
vaccination vous n'avez aucun malade qui
est en réanimation qui a été vaccinée ce
qui veut dire que les vaccins fonctionne
1 c'était les chiffres qui sont arrivés
notamment dans la littérature anglaise
est et nord américaines c'est à dire que
d'un coup on sait que si vous vacciner
vous ne ferez pas de forme grave
d'accord ça c'est garanti et donc tout
ça tout ça ça veut dire que d'un coup on
vit les patients graves qui sont
réanimation sont toujours toujours ciblé
et c'est vrai qu'on a appris à manier
les anticoagulants pour éviter les
embolies pulmonaires parce qu'ils font
désormais pulmonaire on a diminué les
cas de myocardite parce qu'évidemment
parfois le virus il va dans le coeur et
ils bouffent les le muscle cardiaque
donc un coup ça c'est ça c'est
dramatique on a appris à manier la
circulation extracorporelle quand
vraiment ça ça des failles de tous les
côtés on a on a réussi c'est
extraordinaire ce soit dit en passant un
il ya une excellence française sur le
soin parce que on a on a quand même on a
quand même bossé comme des fous et on a
montré des choses au niveau
international donc on a sauvé des vies
on a sauvé des gens deuxièmement ça veut
dire une chose c'est que il va falloir
que les pouvoirs publics
on retombe sur le domaine politique
voilà que les pouvoirs publics
comprennent le problème de l'hôpital
qu'on a fermé trop de lits de
réanimation il va falloir rouvrir
deuxièmement re développer la recherche
pour que cette recherche servent
l'intérêt et la souveraineté
allez on l'a fait large de la france
mais de l'europe et remettre de
l'industrie pharmaceutique et de la
création de l'industrie pharmaceutique
pour faire quoi bien allons enfin quand
vous voyez que ceux qui ont inventé le
vaccin à la rn message icher files
heures il ya des français vous vous
dites mais attendez pourquoi on les a
laissés partir quoi on aurait pu le
faire nous je lis plus le premier brevet
qui a été déposée sur les vaccins arn ya
25 ans il était français sauf qu'il a
été abandonné par la recherche française
a dévalé en a c'est terrible ça on en a
c'est donc parlé ici
on le sait
la réouverture des écoles c'est un des
éléments du déconfinement général qui a
été annoncé et planifiée par le
président de la république suivant un
calendrier qui est désormais connu
alors est ce que vous êtes optimiste
est-ce que vous pensez que ça va bien se
passer
toujours pour chez patrick peloux je me
tourne vers leurs actions mais avant je
voudrais lui faire entendre cette
inquiétude même diffuse du patron de
patrick peloux puisqu'il s'agit de
martin hirsch
le directeur de l'assistance publique
hôpitaux de paris qui était sur france
info ce matin
les gens qui travaillent hôpital sont
très éprouvés très éprouvé c'est une
période qui va être délicate donc la
période
les deux mois qui viennent sur
effectivement deux mois deux ou
progressivement on va retrouver des
marges de liberté mais où si je puis
dire
le sort de l'hôpital est un peu entre
les mains des français il faut laisser
l'hôpital pouvoir être ne pas risquer
d'être re débordées par quelque chose
alors c'est pas très clair mais on a
l'impression qu'il est inquiet c'est
c'est légitime à votre avis la relaxe en
moi je suis raisonnablement optimiste
cette semaine on va dépasser 25% des
français qui ont reçu une injection de
vaccin
c'est à dire plus d'un tiers de la
population adulte
on va avoir un fin mai début juin
vacciner une grosse partie de la
population fragile qui est un risque de
mortalité grave ou de formes graves
oco vide donc on va s'en sortir sur sur
mars
monsieur sûr mais ça va être un petit
peu tendu mais l'augmentation dû rythme
de la vaccination va nous mettre sur une
trajectoire qui ressemble à ce que
israël et angleterre ont eu cet hiver
pourquoi il est comme ça votre chef ou
je sais pas puis j'ai pas bien compris à
vrai dire ce qu'il est ce qu'il a dit
mais on peut serment il c'est mauvais
pour votre augmentation cette année et
bien longtemps que non non j'ai pas bien
saisi parce que je pense que dans la
position où est martin hirsch il devrait
justement expliqué aux pouvoirs publics
l'importance de l'hôpital
il n'ya pas dur aux français de ménager
l'hôpital on est on est la structuration
le socle social on est ce qui fait que
les gens notamment travaillant au samu
de paris et travaillant dans l'urgence
je suis là pour être finalement la
valeur de la fraternité de la solidarité
pour tout un chacun et de l'égalité
républicaine par rapport aux soit c'est
ce qu'ils nous portent tous voila mais à
partir de ce moment là il n'y a pas à
nous économiser c'est juste à
dimensionner correctement et c'est vrai
que je comprends un peu la gêne de
martin hirsch puisque là il faut fermer
près de 400 lits entre les fermetures de
bichat beaujon garches jean verdier donc
on continue les fermetures
quand d'un coup vous avez on a fermé de
manière très maladroite le val de grâce
en 2013 alors qu'il venait d'avoir des
travaux c'est une gabegie total c'est
bien ya-il voilà il ya il ya toute une
dynamique de reconquête du service
public hospitalier à avoir et il n'y a
pas à économiser la ce qu'on est en
train de faire on est en train de faire
partir en vacances les ceux qui n'ont
pas pris suffisamment de vacances etc et
à se préparer à quoi se dire ça se
trouve on va avoir une nouvelle manche
avec le coronavirus en octobre merci
beaucoup à tous les deux se termine par
deux témoignages qui sont intéressants
comme toujours de nos internautes
celui de chardons bleus qui nous disent
c'est halal on revient à l'ouverture des
écoles et savoir si c'est dangereux
chardon midi certains parents refusent
les tests pour ne pas être pénalisé
comme cas contacts c'est le problème
et puis your lemonade sur youtube qui
semble-t-il est enseignant on est collé
ensemble entre 800 élèves avec le masque
9 heures par jour pensez un peu aux
élèves aussi et bien voilà c'est fait en
amont ni à penser on en a parlé
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivis et à
demain
[Musique]